[Applause]
[Music]
good morning
[Applause]
hey girl uh Jimmy Fallon in the house
because Greg is off and you can't really
blame him it's kind of a slow news day
right
some people have asked me offline but
I'm actually not sure what the king of
late night is up to tonight uh but we do
know he's not riding roller coasters at
Six Flags because they have a height
requirement
I love you Greg don't ban me from the
show as for all
three where the hell we after indicting
a president for the first time in our
246 year history that's right America's
246 same age as Dianne Feinstein
[Laughter]
like a lot of you I watched Trump fly
home today after getting indicted and I
gotta be honest I found the whole thing
disturbing but I will admit after two
years of Biden it was refreshing to see
a president make it up the airplane
steps in one shot
thank you
now the good news for the country is
they didn't handcuff Trump so we were
spared the Banana Republic image of a
president in handcuffs yeah Alvin Breg
was in a really tough spot on that one I
mean after all if he handcuffs a
president next thing you know I'll have
to start handcuffing robbers and rapists
and murderers
come on Greg come on man
no no under Alvin Bragg's woke prison
policies New York looks like Gotham City
before Batman comes except Batman ain't
coming because he's not vaccinated nope
but that's where most Americans find
themselves today we're wondering how we
went from feeling like a shining City on
a Hill to a rundown place where you can
buy a house for a dollar you know but
enough about cat's hometown of Detroit
I love you cat we were told Trump got
indicted because nobody was above the
law but Alvin Bragg is lowered 52
percent of violent felonies to a
misdemeanor that's why no objective
Observer sees this indictment as
anything more than a political
persecution
Alvin Bragg ran for office on a vow that
he would arrest Donald Trump and he did
this in New York City a town that's so
liberal they wanted to defund the cop in
the Village People
thank you
[Laughter]
Jimmy which is why Alvin Breg has
everything to win even if he loses the
case you see Democrats have a long
history of failing upwards simply by
becoming National names and if you don't
believe me ask mayor Pete booty who did
such a poor job with the roads in South
Bend Indiana the locals nicknamed him
pothole Pete
now in mayor Pete's defense it's hard to
fix potholes and breastfeed babies at
the same time
but throw in a failed presidential run
and the next thing you know pothole Pete
was in charge of every road in America
as Transportation secretary Pete is it
an insane to think pothole Pete is in
charge of Transportation that's like
having an education secretary named
summer school Sal you know
or a vice president named Kamala Harris
she's another person who failed her way
to hire office Kamal Iran for the
Democratic nomination and was polling it
one percent when she dropped out think
about that our first female vice
president was less popular with
Americans than Meghan Markle is with
britons
but for Alvin Bragg this is his pothole
Pete moment sure crimes through the roof
women are getting assaulted left and
right in the city but a Democrat D.A
doesn't need to arrest violent felons as
long as he's got Stormy Daniels putting
guys in handcuffs foreign
sorry about that one Melania uh kidding
and that's where we find ourselves
tonight Trump has been indicted because
Alvin Bragg doesn't have the balls to go
after real criminals and Democrats are
fine with it because their obsession
with getting Trump has gotten so
emotional it's denying them the
self-awareness that would otherwise tell
them you know they sound insane to
normal people I mean think about this
Democrats swore Trump colluded with
Russia to swing an election and when
that didn't work they impeached him for
meddling in Ukraine when that didn't
work they impeached him for trying to
Stage a coup and when that didn't work
they raided his house and said he stole
classified documents none of it worked
but today they finally got their big
moment Trump got arrested for financial
crimes dude this was their OJ Chase but
in this instance the guy they claimed
had murdered Nicole is only being
charged with double parking outside her
house
and they expect every one of us to be
just as excited as they are because they
don't have the self-awareness to realize
most people look at them and saying yo
these are crazy
so true
Donald Trump was the first president to
be impeached twice that went nowhere now
he's become the first president to be
arrested that'll go nowhere they say you
never forget your first you know unless
it was with Bill Cosby
um
I
and by the way don't come at me with
that Cosby joke he is out of jail by the
way
as far as I'm concerned this whole case
is just a He Said She Said She Said She
Said She Said She Said
it's a stupid joke but nothing's a
stupid or Dumber joke than this
indictment Democrats would have you
believe they arrested a former president
because the man is out of control but
history will show that they were and you
know for all I know who knows how it
will play out but the party that gave us
two terms of Bill Clinton is once again
trying to convince you that Donald Trump
is the most disgusting thing that's ever
happened in the Oval Office to which I
say close but no cigar
[Applause]
guests as a former Miss Florida Citrus
her Talent was having teeth former State
Department spokeswoman and founder of
Polaris National Security Morgan Ortegas
is here
[Music]
when you talk about the best hosts on
Fox Business he's met both of them
co-host of the big money show Brian
brenberg in the house
if he looked any younger the Democrats
would take him to a drag show
Joe Guy Benson is here
and she was just indicted today on 34
counts of being awesome you damn right
Fox News contributed
is in the house
hey everybody it's only shocking when
someone says anything nice together
why'd you throw her off like that I
don't know what to do are you a little
freaked out in New York when someone's
nice it usually means they're robbing
right you know what I mean like grab
your wallet um but let me jump in on
this Alvin Bragg spoke uh shortly before
we came on the air and I want to toss to
that really quick before I ask you a
question
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts laughs
[Laughter]
now I'm going to react to that because
every woman we know in Manhattan carries
two cans of maize in case they run into
Joe Mackey on the subway but stick with
the point is no woman feels safe in
Manhattan isn't he already minimizing
and normalizing serious crime
that's so interesting because I don't
think anybody who's actually super
excited that you know Trump got indicted
is actually going on and on about this
specific crime they're like we can't let
this ever happen this was so bad they go
on about how much they hate him and how
they want him to go away and he deserves
it because he's such a bad person so
they really broaden the scope and and
yeah in New York it's just there's a lot
of crime it's gross it's ugly I was in
Charleston last weekend and you know we
were like talking to a bartender I was
with my husband I was like it's so nice
here it's so pretty like there's no
needles anywhere
and they were like
yeah
I guess it's like not a thing most other
places oh no New York is just a dump
uniquely disgusting right but on the
other side of that it's also expensive
it is it's right at least it is New York
is like a spiritual dominatrix it takes
all your money it calls you names it's
crazy uh brenberg I want to go to you
really quick uh you told me backstage
you watched all the Stormy Daniels
videos to prepare for this
I know
I can't go on this show I can't go on
the show The thing about you book a
business guy they're going to do the
research
they're going to do the research I'm a
scholar I'm kidding I'm kidding he's a
good decent man but there's another clip
of Alvin Bragg I want to speak to and I
want you to react to this really quick
can you give me the other brag that is
why we have a history in the Manhattan
DA's Office of vigorously enforcing
white collar crime
this charge it can be said is the bread
and butter of our White Collar work at
its core
this case today is one with allegations
like so many of our White Collar cases
the reason I made an adult movie joke is
doesn't that read like The Thin plot of
an adult movie after all of this he's
trying to sell us class Warfare well he
said the word vigorous enforcement I was
in my office I couldn't hear it from the
sirens on the street below like I can't
hear you Above This I love the woman
yelling okay can I take this somewhere I
was watching all this unfold today this
is where my mind goes remember the movie
Strange Brew Bob and Doug McKenzie want
a free beer so they put a mouse in a
beer bottle and bring it to the brewery
he put 34 mice in 34 beer bottles
brought him to the brewery and
everyone's like we see what you did here
there's nothing here that's how this
played out today
well listen it's still better than what
Bud Light did with a beer bottle this
week but we'll get there we'll get there
we'll get there uh Morgan the Democrats
love to allow you know um they love to
lecture us about the importance of
protecting democracy yes but would you
say that this is kind of not that to be
arresting a major party nominee and
having a trial that'll kick off in
primary season well not only would I say
that we're seeing foreign leaders say
that uh the president of El Salvador
came out today and said what you've seen
in America is uh the opposition
candidate that the leading person for
the presidential nomination and in fact
beating Biden in plenty of polls has
been arrested and and the president of
El Salvador said how can America I'm
paraphrasing but essentially how can
America now lecture about democracy in
their foreign policy seeing this today
you're also seeing uh this has United
the never Trump and the full Trump parts
of the Republican Party Mitt Romney gave
a very robust defense of the president
today uh president Trump that's not
something I thought I would have said
anytime soon Jeb Bush defended him so
you know I guess Alvin Brad has has done
something finally for the Republican
Party he got never trumpers to come
around so who knew I mean you know
you're screwed up when you piss off the
guy in mom jeans
[Laughter]
like mom jeans you know they're hot I
mean look am I going to judge anyone's
fashion what I'm wearing no not with
that pink Blazer on hey girl uh guy let
me ask you this though for real on a
serious political level are we being a
prisoner of the moment in saying this
helps Trump because getting past this
moment when it comes time to court you
know independent voters in the general
election is this baggage gonna scare
people away is that kind of the point of
this first of all I defend your pink
jacket yeah you do yes yes
on arraignment day we wear pink thank
you on this show hey ortegasus I am too
thank you I just remembered how about
you defund the fashion police how about
that girlfriend I kidding we love you go
ahead um
in the moment this does help Trump in
Republican politics because of the rally
around the flag effect that Morgan just
referenced and his first job if he wants
to be president again is to win the
Republican primary yeah so I would
imagine his attitude would be if I get
to that point then I'll figure out how
to appeal to Independence and that sort
of thing I also think that
we're making a lot of declarative hot
take statements right now about what
this will mean nine months from now
um I would just pump the brakes on that
a little bit we have very short
attention spans in this country news
Cycles move very fast but in terms of
fundraising and polls and that sort of
thing and just a genuine sense of
outrage like are they really doing this
the first time in history is for this uh
obviously near term this is helping him
yeah okay he's going to make some money
he's raised what did you say Brenda give
the business guy eight million I think
eight million bucks yeah I mean Alvin
Briggs the best fundraiser he's ever had
and the biggest uniter in the Republican
party I don't think he set out to do
either one of those things but man he's
succeeding in that front now is it true
because Biden was asked before he came
on the air and he didn't comment is it
because he thinks Alvin has a brother
named Simon and Theodore
he's got his cassette tapes in there and
he's playing them in Fast Forward I told
those Rascals not to do it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and mo most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else